and now it's time for bumming reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review
Tron lazy
oh my god you did a greatest movie I've
ever seen in my life something really
clever having to do with transporters
versus movies that came out called Tron
it was a gigantic bomb but then all
these gates of movie buffs gathered
together and said it wasn't a bit so
they made a good trillion-dollar sequel
so the first movie is about how Jeff
Bridges went into a video game
I went into a video game once Mario is
actually Scottish for the second movies
about how Jeff Bridges goes into a video
game and never returns
but his son named Sam the files to find
him so Sam just sucked into the world
known as the grid which pretty much
looks like the last 10 minutes of 2001
and he comes across Jeff Bridges only
it's not two bridges if there's another
Jeff Bridges wait a minute a movie
woodchip bridges and two mistaken
identities oh my god - yeah man else AV
universe just pour me another wet
brushes awesome don't rinse out there's
two different kinds of Jeff Bridges
co-directed and the one dude the younger
ones not so nice you see the older one
program that younger ones to create this
utopian society it'll be awesome man
we'll be drinking smoking pot and
listening to pointless sommelier cameos
but the young bridges it's like in order
for everything to be perfect all floss
must be destroyed our oh man you're
flawed Oh die so they alter temperature
stick to the outskirts of the grid where
nobody else to go why does a really hot
chick in it
her name is Cara and she's part of a
group of people that just invented
themselves
we were just born one day and decided to
create ourselves but the engine produces
like they are flawed I'm gonna blow them
all up well nobody's perfect yet
now they are summaries his son is like
how come you never came back portal can
only be open for a certain amount of
time man why is that science babble
science babble science science science
babble babble science science babble
science science science babble science
babble babble so they figure out the
only way to get out there is talk to a
guy named Seuss and I'm like dude Thor
is coming up next to your PS then that's
awesome so soon as I can wow I can take
you to Zeus and it's not me are you dude
yeah oh dude you just show that my ass
do you also try to betray you kill you
ooh girl I'll throw that in for free
and so the see all separate is and the
old Jeopardy's is like dude man we can
make it to the portal let's open again
but let me guess we don't have an
out-of-time dude
so they rush to the portal as fast as
they tend but you see these TIE fighters
that were made by my bright light bright
light bright the perfect device to start
effect words so there's a lot of flying
and dying and shooting and screaming it
sounds like my family reunion I'll tell
they finally get to the portal by young
Jeff Bridges is there to stop em dude
dude I'm sorry I made you such a dick
man it's cool now die Cooper corslet
past him and make it to the portal and
the young Jeff Bridges tries to stop
them but the old Jeff Bridges sucks it
back oh come on they don't destroy each
other and Sam and Clark get away so Mike
could alter bridges use those sucking
powers before there's a really hot chick
in it
so Sam goes on to only his own company
corn starts her own business called make
yourself yourself and the only happily
ever after oh yeah and tremana briefly
very briefly and thank you barely see
him you know for a movie series called
trying you know see much of Tron in the
second one it's like holy shit words
list
pancake sure is a decent movie but I
want to see a pancake or some oatmeal
Depp you could twist this is jittery
boozing
come on change come on help me make the
movie pancake I even got a sequel called
pancake new moon